reject nation welcome to the most
speculative episode of koi's comic
corner to date this is all stuff that
i'm just theorizing having seen thor
love and thunder once and how i think
that sets up guardians of the galaxy 3
and what guardians of the galaxy 3 might
even be please do leave a like subscribe
hit that bell leave a comment i've been
loving reading what you guys are
suggesting i talk about on this very
show and please do check out my tic toc
it's koi jondro for 15 second one minute
and three minute versions of this very
thing ranting theorizing comic
recommending all of the above thank you
so much for watching let's talk about
what this magical experience sets up and
a thing that a lot of people on the
internet aren't discussing just yet so i
personally think that the end of
guardians as we know them to date going
off into space in thor love and thunder
mirrors beautifully the moment in
eternals at the end where they go off
into space to meet some gods i don't
know how this isn't the biggest
conversation for people that have seen
the movies so far but these movies
literally have groups teams in the mcu
going off to meet gods that is a lot of
paralleling i think the eternals is
vital for phase four i think the
eternals is foundational for a lot of
the things and i'm gonna get into a tin
foil hat theory near the end of this
video but i do think it is not a
coincidence that we last saw the
guardians going off into space and it
seems like we've got the high
evolutionary as the villain of guardians
of the galaxy 3 as well as adam warlock
so i think the plot might be considering
spoiler alert thor love and thunder the
guardians of the galaxy are
simultaneously trying to save gods as
thor is and spoiler alert thor
accomplishes his goal he stops gore he
does not kill all the gods but we're
hearing more and more that there was a
longer cut of this film that was so
violent that it would like you know walk
that r rating line christian bale has
said that there were things that had to
be cut tyke has also said the assembly
cut of this film which is always very
long don't come at me snyder cut bros it
was like four hours doesn't mean that's
a finished movie doesn't mean we need
the ytt cut this is the cut he wanted
but that does mean there is a lot of
things they couldn't include in this
movie for tone reasons that means
somewhere out there the guardians are
preventing some of this carnage pun
intended he's not a god but he's a
symbiote out in space but i do think the
guardians are going to start the movie
doing the task that they said they'd be
doing i think that might be how we
encounter adam warlock adam warlock is
in guardians one in a you know cocoon
situation and he's been teasing all
these movies he's been cast as the very
very handsome will poulter confusing
people that don't know how puberty works
will poulter's been handsome now he's
just shredded but adam warlock is going
to be i think discovered while they're
trying to save gods i think adam warlock
is going to be this very fish out of
water character that might help protect
them from high evolutionary or even help
them in saving these gods you need a
very powerful character also don't think
it's a coincidence that our star-lord is
half-god i think that might come into
play remember he's the son of ego the
living planet there is a level of god to
him he was able to wield an infinity
stone which doesn't get talked about
enough so i think that's all going to
come into play in him trying to save the
gods we also still don't know how gamora
comes back into play high evolutionary
is a very complicated character high
evolutionary is theoretically our
villain of this movie he's been cast but
we don't know how he's going to be
utilized obviously he basically can
evolve things rapidly he can try to make
things the best version of themselves
and he does that to the detriment
sometimes of the thing that might be a
factor with gamora i don't know if he's
going to try to you know mentally
manipulate her i honestly don't know how
they're going to use high evolutionary
because it's one a character i will
fully admit i don't know as well as
others there might be people in the
comments right now like that's not high
evolutionary there's a lot of
interpretations he's not like kang in
that it changes because the writer
because he can travel through time he's
like a 70s character that someone
thought high evolutionary was this
someone else thought was another thing
because that's a very vague concept of
evolving things so that's beautiful for
james gunn look what james gunn did with
the suicide squad you've got a
foundation of madness you go crazy what
better villain what better character
than a god
golden deity in adam warlock versus a
thing that evolves things maniacally a
mad scientist gone awry to deal with the
chaos of the guardians of the galaxy
trying to save gods i think all of this
conflict is perfect and i do think the
eternals trying to save the celestials
trying to do all of these very very
above
god level things do tie together and i
do think the foundation of fastos tying
everything in together is going to be
the big unifying thing that makes phase
4 tick so imagine the eternals are
hunting celestials a form of god
effectively and the guardians are
hunting literal olympian greek gods to
protect them also in spaceships it's a
small universe i do think they're gonna
be both on ships i do think we're gonna
see those teams interact and i do think
it's gonna be even if you don't love
eternals it's always exciting when teams
come together comic books are all about
team ups and when they're teams of team
ups it's gonna be really special to see
certain characters interacting with
certain characters that's the fun of
these movies that's the fun of a shared
universe two teams went out into space
it'd be kind of a waste if they didn't
meet up to save some gods together i
think it's probably inevitable and i
think it'll also make for some
interesting commentary on what olympian
gods are versus space gods like the
celestials what moon knights gods are
versus the pantheon gods i do still
think that was bossed at the pantheon i
do still think that was the avatar for
the black panther god and i'm wondering
if by the time we get to wakanda forever
we find that out i wonder if we meet her
and go like oh that was an easter egg i
do think we're going to be getting into
more and more of the god elements
especially with the gin in miss marvel
this is being shot before episode 4 of
ms marvel so in discussing the gods and
those elements of ms marvel honestly as
of now as of episode 3 i think the jinn
are a mislead i don't know if that means
it's going to be cree i don't know if
that's going to be in humans i don't
know if it's just a different kind of
underworld but we do already have the
field of reads and moon knight and
valhalla as well as other commentaries
and afterlife so gods are a very broad
thing i do think that's the unifying
force of phase four is the afterlife
gods eternals those bigger than life
beings because we've had the street
level marvel we've had the celestial
marvel i think we're getting into
deities marvel so i think what happens
to unify phase four is we see that
fastos maybe was the one that invented
the ten rings in chongqi maybe he was
the one again haven't seen episode four
on yet that invented the bangle in miss
marvel maybe fastos has been doing
things on the ground floor of earth that
caused a lot of these things to tie into
the gods themselves and if you can tell
things are going wacky and 70s and
insane we're getting into very deep jim
starlin territory we're going full kirby
with these characters what better way to
have guardians of the galaxy 3 tie into
the other elements of the universe than
the eternals making it all one more
cohesive thing so again tinfoil hat
theory i think fastos and the eternals
and their connection to the celestials
tie into what we're about to have in
guardians of the galaxy three maybe even
tying into miss marvel i could be
completely wrong you could be watching
this you're like koi two weeks ago it
was clearly the gin you're an idiot i
don't know yet but i think it'd be
really interesting to have two super
teams come together and i do think we're
gonna have a lot of bloodshed with
guardians of the galaxy three i think
the eternals make it i think most of the
guardians don't i think in fighting the
high evolutionary we lose a lot of the
team i think in trying to save gods we
might even lose a few members at the top
of the movie i can see this being a
really sad conclusion of the trilogy
because james gunn loves to kill
characters he did the suicide squad for
a reason so i think guardians 3 a lot of
bloodshed a lot of high concept big
larger-than-life visuals a lot of things
that do ground us weirdly back into
phase four and unify the whole thing and
they've also you might remember have a
christmas special in between so we're
getting guardians times two two
different formats one in disney plus and
lots of other things that might tie it
all together and we're getting werewolf
by night before that which is
supernatural more god things and one
thing i wanted to mention is that
singularity is the character introduced
in the last five minutes of thor love
and thunder and i gotta say having the
title of the movie be not a punch line
but a an explanation the love and
thunder was brilliant but singularity
herself is an all-powerful being that is
introduced in a force which is an
all-female avengers team and then
becomes friends of the kamala khan and i
think she's going to be used in the
young avengers she's not a young avenger
in the comic books but she is a team
member again of a force and i do think
that using an all-powerful god entity in
the young avengers adds some stakes i
think as marvel goes more cosmic goes
into more of the god thing it allows us
to have an anchor with the young
avengers having a young god she is
literally the singularity she is an
all-powerful being and as we see in the
end she fights for thor so i think while
we have thor as a father figure kind of
maybe overseeing the young avengers
having his daughter be a god will tie
beautifully into guardians 3 will tie
beautifully into all the things i think
we're getting to and give us another
member of the team that i don't think
anyone was expecting when you look at
the young avengers you've got certain
expectations you've got certain members
we all thought kate bishop we all
thought certain characters singularity
is only in 23 issues of comic books
check out a force check out some of the
ultimate stuff it is a fascinating
character that i think will be an
integral young avenger and maybe the
biggest twist we've been thrown from
kevin feige setting up the young
avengers all of this could be completely
wrong my crazy theory hopefully you
enjoyed the uh the madness greg anything
else so to conclude this i usually give
comic recommendations what's hard about
this is since i'm theorizing something
that doesn't quite exist in the comic
books it's tricky so i'd recommend
checking out the bendis run of guardians
of the galaxy i'd recommend the abnet
run of guardians of the galaxy i'd also
recommend you check out the newest run
of the eternals that's still actually
ongoing it's got some of the most
beautiful eternals art and it deals with
thanos so it feels a little bit more
approachable than a lot of the older
kirby stuff which is very esoteric and
strange though lovely and if you like
the weirder side of marvel go back and
read the original kirby eternals because
i do think that kind of visual and that
kind of holy crap how does this exist is
coming to guardians of the galaxy three
so strap in for marvel to get even
weirder with james gunn steering the
ship with high evolutionary adam warlock
and maybe an eternals team up on all
that maybe tying in to the ground level
stuff we have today leading to battle
world secret wars and even bigger stuff
and that's another video thank you so
much for listening to me potentially
rant about stuff that's not gonna happen
this was all a deep cut theory video
please leave a comment below let me know
if you think i'm just making sure well i
didn't make [ __ ] up but if you think the
[ __ ] i made up was correct this is all a
theory of mine i could be totally wrong
argue with me in the comments i'll
probably read it get a little insulted
but comment back just be nice adjacent
thank you to the real rejects for giving
me this beautiful place to have
harebrained tin foil hat theories thank
you for supporting the show and leaving
comments with suggestions of other
things to watch other things to comment
on other things to make videos about hit
that bell so you can get notified of
other weird koi's comic corners of both
the streamlined and esoteric as this was
i appreciate you very much rejectation
we'll see you next time
[Music]